you see the virus is continuing to
change
it's mutating and it forms
new types of virus that have different
capacities to infect
and also they do seem to be able to
start breaking past the defense
that's there from the vaccines and so as
well as using
vaccine as part of our defense we're
going to have to continue
by uh keeping a bit of a distance from
each other and
and i'm going to suggest that the
physical distancing part of one meter
plus
and mask wearing will be necessary
particularly in places
where there's a lot of virus we can't
just simply
ignore that so we've got to keep the
precautions in place we've got to have
really good test trace and isolate
systems that can pick up people with
disease
and get everybody isolated if they need
to be
and at the same time we will have to
continue with the vaccination program
and it will include boosters
so are you saying that people who are
working in offices
should still wear masks and be more than
a meter apart
there will be a need for every single
workplace
to be asking uh is it right
that we stop wearing masks and stop
maintaining distance
because that's the way you prevent
people from getting infected
and that's the key to stopping big
spikes building up
uh i personally am okay about
trying to find ways to get groups
together again i'm okay
about trying to restart the economy
because that's what has to happen
but i'm also saying the virus is still
in our midst and the virus is mutating
so we have to go
on being careful about it and i am
advocating continued physical distancing
continued mask wearing
for the time being including in
countries where there's a lot of
vaccination
how are you feeling dr david about the
delta plus
variant that we're hearing about it's
only a handful of cases at this stage
but it is being picked up
yes and that issue of variance is what
we are watching
uh all over the world they are going to
go on coming
we will go from delta to lambda and then
on to the
other greek letters uh that's inevitable
and some of these variants will be
troublesome
they will be able to break through the
vaccine
related protection in a few people and
that will cause problems
i'm basically saying variants are going
to go on coming
that's part of life we need to pick them
up fast we need to move quickly if we
see them
in a spa in a certain location and we
need to build the management of variants
into what we call our kobit ready
strategy
which is going to be the pattern for the
foreseeable future and how are you
feeling dr david about people
flying around the world
uh you know we really need to be careful
about this
uh only absolutely essential travel now
essential can be essential for emotional
reasons as well as essential for work
reasons
but essential really matters just it's
not
yet the time for unrestricted travel to
start
there are too many risks i believe
and uh i think that the possibility of
initiating another major explosive
outbreak because of a
an event in a particular location that's
done for leisure
it's too serious so i'm basically
suggesting
keep being keep being aware of this
virus and keep working hard to avoid it
and don't do don't do shortcuts because
just because we want to be strong in the
face of the virus doesn't mean that it
uh curls up and goes away no it can come
back with a vengeance so
keep recognizing it's there keep
behaving carefully
and and don't do things that you don't
need to do